[Musique]
un petit moment qu'ils étaient dans la
chance mais quatre ans c'est bien ce que
je vais manger décidé de confier un
important voyage d'affaires tu pars
trois jours à barcelone en espagne et je
me dis que ton énergie sera l'armé
absolue pour convaincre les clients
commencent à mon énergie
oui ton énergie tu vois ce que je veux
dire ton ambition pourquoi tu mets des
guillemets partout parce qu'en fait je
parle de ton cul bon voyage à barcelone
amuse-toi bien cool je prends deux jours
de congé et je pars avec toi ouais et
moi je suis free lance alors je pars
quand je veux c'est un voyage d'affaires
c'est pas un week-end entre copines
désolé vous venez pas aussi j'adore les
chambres d'hôtel j'ai l'impression
qu'ici tout est permis
nicky vois tu es sûr ah j'avais pas vu
que c'était deux lits doubles ensemble
les filles la dj trop canon c'est le
meilleur de tous un véritable artiste
voir ce mec je m'appelle les eaux c'est
un plaisir je m'appelle harper est ce
que tu restes dans quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais la bride
on avait un vrai lien il y avait des
étincelles regarde ça ya ton mec léo
ouest qui joue à ibiza dans quelques
heures
non je vais pas aller à ibiza j'ai un
rendez-vous super important ici le
lendemain son destin il ya des gens qui
vont dans l'espace d'autres qui soigne
le cancer et toi ton but c'est te faire
ce dj ben ouais moi je trouve que les a
carrément raison c'est en but c'est une
voyage s'arrêtait là et que c'était sa
note meilleurs souvenirs je serais déjà
bien contente je n'arrête pas de penser
à toi
les filles ça pourrait être ma dernière
chance de le revoir de toute ma vie
il ya une de 24 heures que j'ai aucune
nouvelle qu'est ce que tu fous
maintenant j'en ai plus rien à péter
alors on va faire la fête comme des
malades
qu'est ce que tu fais
[Applaudissements]
je me suis fait chier c'est pas encore
ça lui sauver
les chambres d'hôtel c'est le cauchemar
quand éclair à la lumière noire tu vois
apparaître des taches de sperme partager
une appli pour faire de la lumière noire
vous peut vérifier cette histoire de
sperme
[ __ ] j'y crois pas vrai
toujours pas tous les murs et dimanche